if you look at what Ronda Sis's campaign
has been like your only conclusion could
be that he is being sabotaged have you
seen him wearing the high heels oh the
cowboy boots with the big lifts big
lifts is an
understatement you should just gone
straight to platforms you know the the
the the front of the boo flat and bent
like there's no foot in it his it looks
like his foot is pressed up against the
front of the boot and there's a 4in lift
in them now I'm not saying I know for a
fact that's true but these are the memes
that are coming out you look at how um
you know Ashley stclair made a joke
about it and Christina Pasar starts
attacking her and I'm like is is are
like are they intentionally nuking the
first thing I said was I believe that
Ron ronda's campaign staff are secret
Trump supporters who are intentionally
nuking his campaign to help Trump then I
thought about it I'm like maybe the real
goal is to stop Dan Sanz from having
teamed up with Trump in the first place
because now that relationship is is uh
Beyond repair yeah